je vous ordonne d'atterrir immédiatement
ok les crevards ans la série je répète
nouveau ordonnance atterrir immédiate
[Musique]
merde
c'est chez toi ici pour les dégâts et ça
c'est un petit bonus pour taseer salut
ma puce mais pour ton vélo
vous m'avez jamais vu
c'est à la cia non non independiente et
version consulting y a
c'est ouais vous dirige auriez la boîte
mais le reste du temps vous passeriez
pour nous il prend des photos
disons qu'ils recueillent des
informations alors si quelqu'un le
découvre et la famille les amis ou même
lui si celui-ci c'est ça c'est ça ce
sera un problème c'est légal tout ça
quand on est du côté des gentils
il faut juste pas se faire gauler
merci de venir me voir et écouter il
doit y avoir une petite erreur parce que
je n'avais pas prévu de ces messieurs
sont venus me chercher à l'aéroport j'ai
ramené asseyez-vous un café mais si vous
connaissez mon nom bozec reading qui
vient ici chaque semaine et qui prend
des photos avec son bel avion à huy
ces photos voyez j'ai une une société
d'aviation et si on à meyrin sud et les
donne des conseils
lily a cessé sa au plus tôt la cia qua
non non non non non je viens juste faire
du business wire fait du business line
pôle export au bétail
mais aujourd'hui les seniors a offert à
ses poupées de nouvelles richesses
monsieur c et vous pourriez nous aider
vous connaissez les plans de vol vous
pouvez faire des allers-retours à los
estados unidos avec votre mais l'avion
est de quelle richesse on parle
exactement
easy la jonte américaine de lutte
antidrogue à des rites et immédiatement
hôtel à niamey mais quelques coups
[Musique]
tiens pour ton vélo vous m'avez jamais
vu c'est plus grand trafiquant qu'on
connaisse armes drogue blanchiment
d'argent
vous saviez vous que les plus grands
coffres cse des cadillac
j'en offre une à chacun de vous pour
récompenser vos efforts ils vont me
relâcher et vous aurez beau faire ça n'y
changera rien il peut partir dont on
retombe et vous auriez dû prendre les
cadillac
je bossais pour la cia et pablo escobar
en squad et rsa au milieu du jardin ya
des billets éparpillés un peu partout je
ramasserait demain matin tous les toits
la gringo
tu me fais confiance non
[Musique]